so jim you're still doing stand-up
during these times so how are you making
that happen
and is it better or worse well i
you know i've become so dependent
on a certain endorphin rush you know i
i don't know how often you consistently
perform obviously this is a
this show is a creative outlet obviously
but
like i did stand up 300 nights a year
for 30 years and then for four months i
didn't
so there was something about i was
craving the performance but
it's weird so i do these drive-in shows
where i essentially do
you know there's everyone's safe social
distance a parking lot a
parking parked car away from each other
but you're performing for cars so it's a
little bit
like uh being in that movie cars like i
feel like i'm mater
you know like i'm on stage and i'm the
car
performing i'm like and it's weird
because
you know the the feedback rather than
applause or laughter
is flashing lights so people will flash
their lights occasionally they'll beep
they'll be like you know kind of like
get out of the way beep
is good joke it's weird it's a different
type of language
oh that's such a cool and clever idea
though just to get people one out of
their house but they're safe and
all of that that's a really great idea
um and i love a drive-in
movie theater um yeah i think they're so
awesome um and
and personal and fun and kind of a whole
experience subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going